foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight a
damning report says the cricket is
racist so Mr Churchill has been branded
a white supremacist Britain's most
shocking race murder is back in the
headlines does this all mean that
Britain is a racist country or do you
have a problem with celebrating real
progress to Trevor Phillips joins me
live
also tonight Hancock in the dock the
UK's pandemic Health Chief takes to the
stand of the covert inquiry but will the
victims of the government's mistakes
ever get the Justice they want or debate
that thus mortgages exploding inflation
soaring kids living with their parents
till they're Grail bald is it any Wonder
young people hate capitalism well they
got it all wrong we'll debate that too
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening London welcome to Piers
Morgan and censored is Britain a racist
country
if you watch the news or read social
media there's a lot of evidence that
suggests it might be the racist murderer
Stephen Lawrence is back in the
headlines London's met police has been
branded institutionally racist an
exhibition that supports Cathedral
branded Sir Winston Churchill one of our
great national heroes a white
supremacist and a shocking new report
today declared that Cricket that most
English of indulgences is elitist
misogynist and institutionally racist an
independent commission found that racism
is entrenched in the sport and that
players at all levels of the game face
discrimination because of their class
and their skin color
if you're not white male and Wealthy it
seems you're not welcome in that great
English game now for the many people who
love Cricket myself included it's
literally my favorite sport in the world
I'll be in Residence at Lords this week
for the ashes this report makes
unsettling reading but it's also not
really the sport that I recognize or
many of the people that I've played
Cricket with recognize from fans
understands to players on the pitch most
of the people I've ever encountered
Cricket are not racist or sexist but
indisputably this report affirms that
this is going on attitudes have changed
as the times have changed and that's
indisputable too I think that's how a
lot of people feel when they see
headlines like this there are problems
in our society yes but there has been
massive progress too last week we marked
the 75th anniversary of an event that
changed the country 492 people stepped
off the Empire Windrush from the
Caribbean into the gloomy gray swirls of
Britain they were the Pioneers the first
in a wave of new arrivals over a period
of decades who became the Windrush
generation Britain invited people from
across the former Empire to fill labor
shortages and rebuild our battered
economy after the war and they did just
that they became factory work but
cleaners nurses in the brand new NHS
they changed the face of this country
and they changed it for the better but
it wasn't all a fairy tale along with
the bad food and worse weather these
people faced a very hostile reception
from many they were ostracized bullied
and abused they faced keep Britain white
signs Enoch Powell's rivers of blood
speech there were race eight riots that
were Teddy Boys in Nottingham and London
it was a racist country for many of
those who came over in the Windrush
generation but three quarters of a
century later in Britain well frankly is
unrecognizable to those times I don't
think most people in this country now
care about skin color they care about
equality and tolerance one in six
britons has a parent born abroad now
there are more black and ethnic minority
people in top government jobs here than
the whole of the European Union put
together we've opened our doors to
massive numbers of Ukrainian refugees
the first minister of Scotland is Muslim
half of the England football team is
black it's not even a topic of
conversation
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak is a
proudly practicing Hindu from East
African and Punjabi descent and when he
got the top job that fact was really
barely a footnote it didn't stop The
Usual Suspects queuing up with
pre-written hot takes like this
there's a part of me that feels a little
bad
for England's racists
no because because remember remember
they voted for brexit specifically
to keep Britain White
and that vote starts with a seven year
chain of dominoes
that has now led directly to an Indian
prime minister
yeah that was complete nonsense by
Trevor Noah who actually left his show
quite recently no flowers need to be
sent nobody cared or does care that
Richie sunnak is in white if it was
mentioned at all to celebrate the fact
we had our first non-white prime
minister but people didn't make a big
deal of that either the exact same can
be said of our old friends Harry and
Megan the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
they've done more than anyone to spin an
alternative reality in which Megan was
hounded out of a vile racist country by
a cruel racist royal family
but it didn't produce any evidence for
that I still haven't and the reality to
me is that we eulogized the newly
biracial monarchy as the fresh face of
21st century Britain I wrote newspaper
columns about it myself what a breath of
fresh air this was
nobody will argue there isn't racism in
Britain today and there isn't a lot of
work still to do but the fact that
Britain is one of the most diverse
welcoming and tolerant countries in the
world it's something to be proud of the
public Fury with the conservative
government over the wrongful deportation
of some of the Windrush generation is to
me more proof of that it may be
fashionable to say Britain is racist but
in my view it is fundamentally wrong
well joining me now is broadcaster Sir
Trevor Phillips is re-released and
updated his book Windrush 75 years of
modern Britain also in the studio talk
to these Paula Roan Adrian and Richard
Tice right there's a lot to unpack here
so Trevor you are probably the most
qualified man in the country to unpack
it with me so let me just start with
that simple question
is Britain a racist country
well as much as it pains me to agree
with you about anything Pierce
um I think actually I reached the same
conclusion as you do when you ask a
question is Britain racist country the
first thing is to ask compared to what
compared to the days when my parents
came here with their nine children I was
the tenth born here and when my father
said that he would have to walk the
streets at night looking for somewhere
to sleep or when we lived in two rooms
no chance of black people getting
Council houses then because Council of
tenants wouldn't have us on the Estates
so we lived in rackman slums in our
family's case two rooms black family
upstairs black family downstairs uh
that's why I went that's why I was sent
back to the Caribbean because you can't
get 12 people into two rooms very
conveniently or compared to when I had
my first girlfriend at University and in
order to meet her mother we had to meet
in selfridges because her mother
couldn't tell her father that her
daughter date was dating somebody black
so I think when people say you know
there's terrible races just talk to your
parents or to talk to your grandparents
now that doesn't mean we're perfect but
if you survey people now on the uh Think
Tank British future did this a couple of
weeks ago eighty percent of people from
ethnic minorities will tell you that
compared to anywhere in the content
continent and by the way compared to the
United States this is a better place to
live if you are not white than anywhere
else in the development when I walk up
and down my local High Street maybe a
couple of times a day it just seems
unbelievably Multicultural London I mean
I don't Venture North a lot when I do it
doesn't feel a lot different actually
when I go to Manchester or places like
that
um it just feels like we live in an
incredibly tolerant Multicultural
environment now I think there are
racists in Britain no question as there
are in every country but my God we've
come a long way I think from that
environment your parents had to come to
yeah I mean let's study on a bit I mean
let's the fact that there are many races
in this country that doesn't make us a
racist Nation but but that doesn't mean
that we don't have problems we don't
have a situation where people who look
like me uh know that when they go for a
job people will smile at them and be
very lovely to them and as soon as they
walk out the door say hello not not
going to have that one because they
won't fit let me give you an example all
sorts of reasons Let me Give an example
I remember watching players like Luther
blissett one of the first black
footballers then John Barnes and others
I remember the monkey chants from The
Terraces I remember the bananas being
thrown on not how they remember it they
were on the receiving end I remember
watching it
and you would never see that in an
English professional game now I mean
it's unheard of you hear about it in
Spain still and countries like that but
not here and I was really struck by for
example the taking the knee the George
Floyd it was it was divisive and
controversial for many people but I got
to say arsenal for example very
Multicultural uh crowd a lot of black
players Mikaya Saka and others it was
always they did it for the whole time
that it went on for the whole season it
was immaculately heard by the Home and
Away crowds I never heard a single boo
now I don't think that would have
happened
even 20 years ago I I think that is true
and you know and Arsenal as a sort of
very polite nice club I mean not a
winning Club but a very nice club uh if
if you went went to uh Chelsea which is
like had been my club for more than half
a century
um when I was a student I stopped going
because of the racism yeah because they
were throwing darts and I was like the I
was like the bullseye in the dartboard
right so I stopped going for a long time
but today you wouldn't get any of that
in charge and in fact well you've had
the occasional but it when it happens
it's really it becomes a big story
exactly it's nothing like the old days
when he had you know the Headhunters and
all that business today our heroes are
Didier Drogba uh kante I mean this is a
whole the country itself has changed and
by the way those people that you saw
coming down the Gangplank from Windrush
they were the people who changed things
they no wait okay so let's move to
something like and I totally agree with
you by the way let's move to Cricket
right now you have a vested interest I
think in the recruitment process for the
chair of this inquiry which has come out
with a pretty damning
317-page report holding up a mirror to
Cricket which has concluded a structural
and institutional racism existing within
the game women are treated as
subordinate to men at all levels of the
sport there's elitism and class-based
discrimination in cricket now and says
black Cricket has been failed and ecmb
must develop a plan to revive it I don't
think people would in the game would
disagree with with that um assessment
some are horrified I mean quite
surprised and shocked on some of it and
I'll come to the racial part in a moment
with you but on the on the part for
example about elitism I remember when I
was 12 I got picked for the England prep
schools Cricket Squad I was a fast
bowler loved Dennis Lilly and I was very
good for my age but I was playing
Cricket three hours a day I was being
trained at my Prep School by former
Hampshire cricketer and I had the
benefit of that privilege and elitist
experience if you like and then I went
to local comprehensive where they
literally played Cricket once a week for
two hours if they could find any of the
meager equipment that they had for all
the children uh and if a teacher could
be bothered to do it which often wasn't
the case so I went from playing three
hours a day to nothing and it seems to
me we we can could be the world beaters
all the time at Cricket in this country
if State schools had anything like the
commitment which would have to come I
guess from Government funding to things
like Cricket which they just don't I
mean they don't so the chances of
breaking through past the more
privileged elitist private school system
as a cricketer they're pretty low yeah
and I think the basic Point here is I
mean I I grew up I was born here but I
grew up in the Caribbean where Cricket
is you know it's it's there's the air
and there's water and then there's
Cricket yeah and they float they all
flow through the Village
um you have we play cricket in the
streets here they play in you know
they'll have Nets at the moment we don't
have any of that in this country and
it's not a surprise then that people
will uh if they're any good if they're
athletic they'll do basketball girls
will play netball the boys will play
football I think I think that this is a
terrible thing to be honest because I
think Cricket is a fantastic sport for
teaching you disciplines uh for teaching
your team uh Team workings on and if I
may say so Cindy Butts who chaired this
inquiry
um I was delighted that she took on the
role because we were asked to find
somebody to do it and she's done a
fantastic job the thing about what she
has said
people need to remember Cricket is more
than a game and okay it's you know I'm a
Western Indian uh that's a religion it's
a religion the Creator is more than a
game but it it also tells you something
about the society the greatest book
about sport ever written Beyond a
boundary by Trinidadian intellectual uh
to CLR James essentially showed that
what happens in the world is paralleled
on the field so for example 60 years ago
in this country we used to have a thing
called Gentleman versus pledge yeah well
you were born yeah exactly the gentleman
had their own Gates yeah yeah exactly
the gentleman were Posh guys who only
played for expenses went through that
one gate to the Pavilion the players
were professionals they went through the
other gate and they worked for a salary
the last game between gentlemen players
Captain the general captured by Lord Ted
Dexter uh the the the players were
captained by Fred Truman son of a minor
when they got rid of gentlemen versus
players that was announcing that Britain
had left that kind of class divide to
some extent behind it and I think what
Cindy's report is doing is something
equally profound saying Britain needs to
leave behind the hidden class divisions
plus the divisions particularly between
men and women
all fast learning stuff
um Paula is Britain a racist country
ah
there are parts of Britain that remain
of the view that people who look like me
shouldn't be here
there are parts of Britain who are
prepared to challenge that view and that
is why we can have the McPherson report
that is why we have the reports that we
do today that come out about Cricket
that is why we can challenge the
Metropolitan Police the London fire
brigade etc etc so um we have
unfortunately lots of individuals who
can give you their experience we
unfortunately have institutions that
have been identified as still well
example and it's hard to think of a more
damaging thing than to have your main
police force in the country condemned as
institutionally racist I mean Richard
this is part of the problem there are
certainly still institutions where you
can just feel that the setup is geared
towards being accused of in many cases
quite rightly institutional racism of a
degree and you highlight the Met police
and we all know there's an absent
absolute horror stories within that
institution you touched on the fire
brigade these are public sector
institutions I think there's far more
progress and overall I don't think we
are a racist country I think we should
celebrate the incredible progress we've
made but there are pockets of it what
troubles me most is those pockets are in
the public sector just coming back to
the cricket pits there are things
actually again that I don't think the
report does Justice to my son plays in
an Oxford League okay there are many
teams there where there are either 100
percent uh Asian ethnicity within the
team or the vast majority of it again I
don't think that is celebrated enough
and appreciated enough so we're making
great progress there's always more to do
but for him to say let's look at the
positives not just beat ourselves what
did you feel about some Paul's Cathedral
having this thing on their website for
what turned out to be a long time
labeling Winston Churchill or white
supremacist I just I just think that's
it's appalling which is one of the
greatest heroes he saved this country
from the ultimate most hideous white
supremacist out of Hitler For Heaven's
Sake and we should be celebrating and
thanking that and for sure he made
mistakes we all do but we are so much
better
racist mistakes Richard I wasn't around
at the time you know what the history
books tell us were those mistakes racist
in today's in today's world we would say
definitely in in the context of then who
knows what it was we weren't around
for us to address that well I am also
got a very I thought Ian Wilson got a
great piece to live for the male when he
said that you have to take all these
people like Churchill Gandhi Mandela in
the totality of what they achieved what
is what is hit uh Church's greatest
achievement it was defeating Hitler the
ultimate white supremacist so I mean
Trevor it's complicated but obviously
some of the things that Churchill said
over the years were racially tinged
there's no question of that
um which was of its time I mean those
kind of comments were not unusual but I
don't think he was a white supremacist
well I think these these phrases are
hurled around as phrases of abuse let's
be clear I mean Churchill for example
you mentioned Gandhi uh Churchill I
think described uh Gandhi as half-naked
Indian Indian fakir a kind of pejorative
dismissive terms but that was a nature
of the English aristocracy at the time
yeah and that was without question a
racist point of view but the important
point is that it was normal and that's
actually I don't I feel really
uncomfortable Paula when we try and
transport the morality of the day back
to previous generations and this brings
me to well I was going to say what what
it should tell us is
it was like that then goodness me now
it's unacceptable now it's unacceptable
and we should really be thinking
constantly
how have we moved this right but this on
that point though Paula this issue of
reparations for example you know people
today paying for the sins of their
ancestors who may have owned slaves
there was an extraordinary Reuters
report today quite I mean hilarious in
some ways do you know who the only
American they charted every American
president's links to slave ownership do
you know the only one who had no direct
links to slave ownership
Donald Trump
you know
even Barack Obama threw his white side
of the family they could chart it back
to slave ownership Trump is the only one
apparently he came after slavery his his
life and we've discussed reparations
before and you know my view I'm very
uncomfortable about the fact that the
British government felt it appropriate
that they should pay back the slave
owners and only finished compensating
them in 2015 and yet when we talk about
reparations to those still affected by
colonialism we are told to shut down
that conversation and that comes back to
what we're discussing about Winston
Churchill if people understood that
Winston Churchill did say things that
were inappropriate the Winston Churchill
did say things or held views that were
racist it's fine to encapsulate them in
at a point of History
we don't know we're not discussing we
don't know we're not hearing it don't
take a place that supports cathedral
which literally was an emblem of the
blitz for goodness sake right when
Churchill stood up and basically
single-handedly motivated this country
to defeat a bunch of white supremacists
from taking us over Trevor can I have to
say on that point I do apologize for
interrupting there are a lot of people
in this country who think that black
people arrived on the Wind Rush that was
that was us stepping into this world
that's not true
we were here long before this I realized
you realize that a lot of people don't
know it's the same in regards to the
history okay let me ask let me ask
Trevor a interesting question in an
interview with a male that you gave you
made the point you were very
disappointed that Megan and Harry had
this amazing opportunity yeah as the
first biracial couple in our monarchy to
really be a force for Change and good
and they blew it yeah by the way I'm not
going to let you get away with the whole
Trump thing still not voting for him
right by the way I've told anyone to
vote for Donald Trump right I'm not
American I wouldn't impinge on their
thing it just was quite funny he read
this report and he was the only one I've
got I've got a lot of American four
sisters who live in New York and they've
got a view about Trump but anyway
um on them Meghan Markle thing look
I think people mistake who Meghan Markle
is
um
she herself said that until she became
this princess she never regarded herself
particularly as black and that's
understandable she grew up uh in Los
Angeles in the most uh wealthy uh black
enclave and anywhere in the United
States Park
um Park View Windsor Hill in Los Angeles
she went to a private uh Roman Catholic
school and in a sense race was never
really part of her background and
actually you knew anybody who from back
from who comes from a black family knew
that this was not her territory when she
made this supposedly incendiary Claim
about somebody asking about what
Archie's skin color will be well
actually every black family of course
the minute that that you know there's
somebody coming that's what you're
speculating about for white people it's
what color hair
particularly in a family if one parent
yeah right yeah and one parent is in her
parents for example but the point I
really want to make about Meghan Markle
is that she had to learn to be black on
the job as it were and I think she made
a bit of a mess of it she didn't take
advice and that's in some sense is why I
think they've squandered the opportunity
right to demonstrate something important
about this country but just very quickly
yeah we have the largest uh unique uh
uniquely mixed race population anywhere
in the developed world that has come
about through romance Roman coercion and
they could have been standards I totally
agree or grimacing I'm quickly because I
I obviously I love so Trevor but we're
going to disagree on that point you
yourself have just said she did a bad
job of learning how to be black why did
this woman this person have to learn how
to be black she had to be learned how to
be black because she had to confront
racists and it was the first time that
she went
there are people in prison now because
of the threats they made to her life and
peers I know you are sensitive to people
who have made threats to people's lives
you will understand that mental strain
that was on her in terms of that and you
know that because you will have read the
reports confront tell me the name of one
person that she confronted she didn't
even hear this remark about Archie it
was reported to her by her I'm
referencing
of police Terror police Neil Bassey who
was interviewed and he informed the
viewer that she had um received a number
of threats to him
I have had a few so far right and they
have been arrested for that and charged
and guilty did she so in terms of that
in terms of that she confronted racism
no she didn't she confronted confronted
threats which we all get in public life
to do with that I've got to leave with
the skin it's an important subject thank
you for all your perspectives I
appreciate it Trevor uh great to see you
again and good luck with the book
Windrush 75 years of modern Britain a
cracking read on says the next Hancock
and madot the former Health secretary
tells the covert inquiry that the UK's
plans to protect Care Homes and the
pandemic was terrible well no bleep
Sherlock after the break
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
former Health secretary Matt Hancock's
turn to face the public inquiry to have
a government handle the covered pandemic
Hancock said that UK's preparations were
too focused on the consequences of a
disaster rather than how to stop it over
the course of three hours the man in
charge of public health throughout Kobe
so the plans put in place to protect
Care Homes were terrible yet of course
previously said that he put a protective
Ring Of Steel around them I'm joined now
my Care Home manager and owner of
Crabtree car Homes care homes in West
Yorkshire David Crabtree and by talk
TV's International editor I'm a
journalist behind the lockdown files
Isabel oh shots Isabel sum up today
well today was Matt Hancock's effort to
set the record straight and to try to
convince everybody that he's sorry for
what happened we saw a a performance
there of somebody who was knew he had to
go through the motions of telling people
that he's sorry for each and every one
of the deaths I don't say that he didn't
mean that from the heart but I don't
think that will satisfy everybody who
has an ax to grind about how he managed
the pandemic he had decided before going
in that he wanted to make one key
argument and he kept returning to it
throughout today's evidence even when it
wasn't relevant you know to the
irritation actually of the Barrister and
his key argument was this that
everything went wrong was primarily due
to the government having ruled out
lockdowns as a strategy before the
pandemic happened so his argument is
that pandemic planning should have
focused on the use of lockdowns rather
than avoiding lockdowns a lot of people
will say it's a precise opposite that
should have happened well let's take a
look at what Hancock said about how
sorry he is he's been apologizing for
almost everything for the last year
I'm profoundly sorry for each death that
has occurred and I also understand
why for some it will be hard to take
that apology from me I understand that I
get it
but it is honest and heartfelt and I'm
not very good at talking about my
emotions and how I feel
um but that is
honest and true
it's just he's just a phony handcuff
absolute phony honestly I just think
he's an actor when he puts on this stuff
we saw it when he went in the jungle
we've seen it ever since the fake tears
he shed to me on GMB about vaccines and
let's get to care homes for a moment
this is a guy of course who repeatedly
boasted about the protective Ring Of
Steel that he had put around Care Homes
this is what he said about Care Homes
today
we didn't even have the data and this is
the work that was ongoing before the
pandemic which is why this statement
here from the guardian reported from the
garden is inaccurate
um there was work on going to try to
find out even the basics of the
provision of social care for instance
how many Care Homes are operating right
now in the UK that was a fact that we
did not know
well let me come to David Crabtree David
we've spoken many times since the start
of the pandemic during it and after
Hancock had always said he put a
protective Ring Of Steel around the uh
Care Homes he also at the start of a
pandemic boasted how well prepared the
country was for this kind of pandemic
neither of those things were true and
today he basically admitted he hadn't
got a clue about what was going on with
our Care Homes and it was terrible
what's your reaction to that
I'm hopeful that this is the last time
that we see this individual in in public
other than on a pantomime playing the
villain at Christmas
he is such a self-serving lying
inadequate sociopath he should be
sponsored by Kleenex tissues
every time he appears in public
the brain then goes back to those awful
awful times where people not not just
the elderly this was dedicated social
Care staff unprotected which he then
said we had a ring of protection around
the man's deluded he believes what he's
saying therefore he can create this
emotion within himself but it's a lie
and I just wish now that this is an
enter the the poor families who lost we
all we lost Care staff we lost Social
Care staff we lost dedicated NHS staff
the man was not fit for purpose he was
the primary man who was supposed to look
at the contingency plans and he believed
some rumor that we were the best in
Europe
who told him this
I I have no idea who he told it but
shouldn't he have checked shouldn't the
captain of the ship have checked before
we all sang yeah I completely agree let
me bring Isabel I mean you know him very
well you wrote this book with him
um I just think he's a phony Hancock and
I think he's delusional and I think he's
desperately trying to reel off the hook
which frankly it seems more and more
certain he is firmly implanted on
there was an extraordinary moment during
the evidence today where Matt Hancock
admitted that he and his Department
didn't even know how many Care Homes
there are in England you would have
thought that this was basic but he
admitted that the whole setup is so
dysfunctional there is so little
coordination although his title is
secretary or was a secretary of state
for Health and Social care he had the
top responsibility for it but actually
didn't have a clue what was going on
there was a very uh it was a pretty Grim
quite literally a bit of footage when he
left the inquiry and the Grim Reaper
literally someone dressed as a grim
reaper appeared on the other side of the
street watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean pretty devastating imagery for
Hancock and frankly I think he deserves
it I think his handling of this pandemic
was absolutely disastrous but the thing
is that the yeah
absolutely believes that he did nothing
wrong I mean one of the hardest things
when I was working with him was to get
him to admit that there were some
failures because you can't have a book
which just says I'm a hero and
everything was brilliant and he really
struggled to come up with examples of
areas where we got things wrong well
exactly well he can't because he's
delusional David you want to come in
there
yeah it's it's it isn't that we got
things wrong it was new and it happened
across the world we were watching France
and Italy and elderly people in Care
Homes die months two months before it
came across the water what compounds it
and what makes me still angry is that he
lied despite the facts this is why your
comment and my comment that is
delusional a delusion is a false belief
that cannot be altered by reason or
factual evidence to the contrary and he
still does he said he gets it he doesn't
get it no he doesn't get it I completely
agree he was so arrogant you know in his
pronouncements there's a ring of Steel
we've never been better prepared none of
it was true and we now know from his own
mouth and this inquiry he knew it wasn't
true he hadn't got a clue about care
homes or how safe they were what sort of
Ring Of Steel there was a protective
shield whatever the phrasals that he
used
um look there's gonna be a lot more
coming off on the discharge of elderly
into care homes which everybody every
scientist that told him don't
push people into Care Homes it's a
breeding ground he did and that caused
masses of deaths 20 30 000 people died
in Care Homes Isabel finally you've had
access to a lot of WhatsApp exchanges
there is a series of whatsapps involving
met Hancock I think from March April
early in the pandemic which was just
never materialized where are those and
it's really disappointing that he wasn't
challenged on that during the exchanges
today
um I I still want to know what's
happened to those messages because the
missing messages missing as far as I'm
concerned because they were not shared
with me are from March 2020 which is the
key time for this particular module of
the covert inquiry which is all about
how prepared were we we need to see
those messages yes we do Isabel and
David thank you very much thank you both
for joining me I appreciate it on sense
of next with the economy and disarray
Fraser Nelson from The Spectator joins
me to make the case for capitalism and
why we've never had it so good that
debate next
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh nonsense to
the economies in the gutter mortgages
exploding inflation soaring and
generation of young people unable to
leave their parents basements Small
Wonder parts of many major studies
suggest that Millennials and gen Z want
to ditch capitalism altogether can we
blame them so has capitalism failed them
or actually as one of my guests is about
to argue is it our best hope to make the
case for capitalism as Fraser Nelson the
esteemed editor of The Spectator and
David Santina sitting next to me well
that was be foaming at the mouth ready
to rebut what phrase is about to say
it's a phrase off you go a defensive
capitalism
well it's better than any alternative
you can measure that's quite simple it
has been the easily the biggest Force
for good in the world over the last
couple of decades especially we've seen
Global poverty rates absolutely collapse
and we've seen health wealth education
and levels of and child mortality I mean
right the level of world poverty has
never come down faster so we're living
in a golden age of poverty reduction
sure the last couple of years are I've
been pretty difficult and nobody's
saying they haven't
um the free market economy the free
enterprise system means things will go
up and down but the overall trend is
absolutely transformative since China
started to get more sort of capitalistic
in its um in business dealings is
poverty has gone through the floor the
same is true with India so I think we've
now got decades worth of hard facts
which prove just how if you want to
tackle poverty if you want to promote
fairness globally then capitalism is the
way to go okay everybody can see you
nodding away Furious sleep no you
weren't
um well I mean the stats speak for
themselves don't they everything Fraser
just said is demonstrably true well I
think in Broad Strokes yes but I'll just
take a little bit of issue with what um
Fraser had to say there about poverty
because I mean actually the truth is we
currently have 14 million people in the
country who are living below the
breadline or at least living hand to
mouth every month and that is actually
pretty similar to what we saw in the
1970s now I'm not going to sit here and
argue that we should suddenly go you
know full Venezuela but I do think there
is an argument for re you know
reconstructing the welfare state which
has been left thread bare by you know
what 20 where has your socialist dream
actually worked at the NHS it's
obviously Venezuela it completely ruined
the country but I I would point you
towards our fantastic Health Care system
which is a socialist you know socialist
in principle and I would also argue that
you know social housing was very good
for many people I mean I'm sure you're a
big fan of right to buy I'm sure Fraser
is as well it was a fantastic program
innately socialist what is your what is
your actual problem with capitalism I
have I don't have a problem with
capitalism as a concept I think British
capital which is what we're seeing right
now and you know the The Strain that we
have the the focus that we have on
paying out dividends to shareholders and
hoping that somehow this kind of
trickles down and feeds people at the
bottom that's a system that is
demonstrably not working right now
that's what we need to look at Fraser
are there two issues here one that
generally speaking going back a hundred
years you can argue as you've done
successfully in this piece that
capitalism has been demonstrably
successful in many parts of the world
but the right now
this country is in a bad place and
partly that could be put down to some of
the capitalist policies
well it depends what you mean by
capitalist policies I mean capitalism in
many ways is just a funny word that
people give to the basic notion of
Freedom if you look at North and South
Korea no prizes for guessing which of
those two countries is doing best and
you know in the 50s it was North Korea
that was doing best but that's in a
global basis of course if you have
freedom politicians will use that
freedom to make wrong decisions in which
case if you print money if you borrow
your way out of every single problem
then eventually there will be a price to
pay for that we're seeing that now in
terms of inflation we're seeing that now
in terms of dysfunction of the welfare
state but I think when it comes to the
welfare state by the way it's hard to
blame capitalism on that that is the
government which is coming up with
pretty bad policies keeping five million
people on out of work benefits and using
mass migration to try to fill the many
gaps in the in the employment Market
there so when we when I talk about
capitalism you're basically talking
about
um about private property about free
trade about Exchange about basically
economic liberalism now that is a system
that can be done well or can be done
badly but as a system is better than any
other that's ever been invented and I'd
struggle to think of many people
thinking actually here Venezuela or any
other socialist countries is doing much
better than we are now we've got our
problems but fewer of them than the um
socialist and communist countries right
over I think it might be more helpful
probably to look closer to home I mean
if we look at Denmark if we look at
Germany we're actually the poor man of
Northern Europe and if you actually look
at some of the research put out by the
labor party not so long ago we are
actually on track to be poorer per
capita than Poland by 2030 I mean that
is absolutely insane if you look at
countries like Denmark if you look at
Norway they've got higher tax than us
they've got a better welfare system and
the people that are healthier they are
happier and they are actually more
prosperous so hammering down on people
in this sort of what does that have to
do with capitalism as a concept well
okay if we look at the sort of
capitalism that we're experiencing at
the moment inequality is widened okay so
there's no there's a shrinking middle
class there is actually no middle so
you've now got the super rich and you've
got the rest of us who are now actually
classified as super poor there needs to
be some kind of scaffolding that pulls
these people further into the middle so
that more people can achieve under
capitalism have we got Fraser in this
country right now a poor performing
capitalism in other words the concepts I
completely concur with you about the
concept is it being executed badly by a
long-running conservative series of
governments
I'm afraid so the conservatives every
time they get into trouble they think
they will steal labor policies if they
tend not to work very well as a result
you're seeing a trend in Europe right
now where voters are turning to the
right from Greece to Finland and in
Britain you're more likely to get the
labor government of the next election
that's because the policies people are
angry about the over-extending of the
environmental regulations the highest
taxes for 77 years the huge government
spending out of all proportion to its
usefulness they've all been brought
about by a conservative government so
sure we can compare ourselves against
Poland Sweden Norway Germany all of them
capitalist countries the questions of
capitalism done well or done badly and
I'm afraid to say that this big
government conservatism which tends not
to trust people with their own money and
Tinker around to pretty bad results is
showing right now as a case study in
capitalism not done particularly well if
you print money if you print most of the
400 billion you use for the furlough
during the lockdowns you've closed down
an economy you you're messing with
people's lives you're messing with the
free market and there will be a big
price to pay as we're currently
discovering Ava can we end this debate
with you agreeing with Fraser I can
agree on two premises but not on the
conclusion I think the taxes are too
high but I would say that in tax in
countries where the taxes are higher
than we have here people are happier and
it's better I think the problem is the
stewardship of the economy not the
system that we're living under a final
question Fraser for you given I've got
you here who's going to be buying the
spectator
maybe you pierce I don't know it depends
there's going to be a long and
illustrious list of people the greatest
magazine in the world is currently up
for auction and I imagine is going to be
a very busy summer with lots of people
wanting to Avail themselves of the
opportunity of a lifetime if they can
afford it well you're the Manchester
United magazines uh aren't you and uh
quite right there should be a frenzied
bidding process uh but good luck with
that phrase you've done a great job with
The Spectator great to have you on the
program appreciate it Ava lovely to see
you you're staying with me for some
exciting breaking news about Piers
Morgan uncensored it's been a well let
me rephrase the title of the show
they're now multiple award-winning Piers
Morgan uncensored there's the clue after
the break big news big trophies thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back I reassembled my stellar
pack for a very important piece of news
involving this program here's Morgan
says it's a welcome back Richard Tice
Paula Ron Adrian and Ava Santino well
the news is this is that unlike my
football team which ended last season
trophyless uh Pittsburgh no sense if
it's gone on a trophy Rampage ever since
my world exclusive interview with
Cristiano Ronaldo uh the world's
greatest ever footballer and so my utter
Joy I was presented with it by Dan
Walker my former Breakfast Television
rival from BBC breakfast who was the man
who on my last day uh presenting Good
Morning Britain before I was so cruelly
removed from the slot because of the
wishes of one M Markle
um I managed to get the ratings of Good
Morning Britain to beat Dan's BBC
breakfast over the first ever time and
then because I had to leave rather
suddenly he he was never able to wrestle
back the title so the Paul bloke then
had to give me this award I mean talk
about a series of
self-inflicted blows for the poor guy
anyway it was a great moment for us for
the show I texted Cristiano in the car
home and you can always tell when
Cristiano's really happy with it because
he uses the word top and he went top top
you're the man top top top top he gave
me six tops Cristiano you are top I've
got six Tops This is for you Christiana
because you are the guy that won US
these Awards without that incredible
interview we wouldn't have had these
Awards so thank you to Cristiano Ronaldo
a great man come back to my pack how do
you feel about being part of a
multi-award-winning show I mean you got
to feel good right I'm hoping to bring
down the tone
it's it's teamwork I mean it's a team
effort it is yeah how many of you were
involved
although I don't know about you but I'm
hoping to get an invite next time
let's talk quickly about this issue so
our nli Lifeboat have accused the
charity being fixated with a woke
Crusade amid a row about alpha male bad
behavior so it's been a full-scale
cultural review at Hastings Lifeboat
station he says it's quite near where I
was brought up reports this female crew
generally on welcome only alpha males
the history of the station are welcome
all Lifeboat staff in order to attend
diversity and inclusivity training uh
there's evidence of racism by way of
lack of opportunities for people of
color races language physically
intimidating Justice towards women so
Ava here's my point about this in the
cricket report interestingly the the
female chair person woman whatever she
wanted I did advise all that I think
rightly said look woke has been hijacked
and we know that I think actually driven
by the work side but it's been hijacked
as part of the cultural Wars many of
which are legitimate things but at its
Essence wokory really to be woke is to
be alert to racial and social injustice
so when I read this I thought it really
depends what's been going on here but on
the face of it
I can't feel Furious that they should at
least investigate it yeah and I think
this is also a really tricky one for a
lot of people because
um many people on the right are furious
with the rnli for saving some of the
migrants or refugees that have been
found in the channel that has been
really frustrating for a lot of people
on the right of the spectrum but look I
mean one of the arguments that has been
levied to them is that women apparently
aren't suitable for the role and that's
just sort of based on assumption look
I'm like if you're the best person for
the role color creed gender whatever you
should be up for what you do need Paula
is opportunity equal opportunity yes
this is Market about all of this I don't
like tokenism yes I believe in
meritocracy yes everyone's going to get
the same crack of the way absolutely and
that's what this internal report seems
to be about saying that we're not going
to tolerate this kind of a behavior it
needs to be Stamped Out what intrigues
me is that the Whistleblower who bought
this report to the newspaper said they
are in a liar clearly wrong about this
and they are not focusing on what's
important well hang on a minute that's
exactly what they're doing Richard
what's important is that actually the
right people get to the boat that
fastest and go and do the best job and
very often that happens to be men I'm
not sure I said very often yeah
the boat fast this is the most important
who is the most capable of doing the job
and I'm not sure many donors to that
charity want their money in 10 years
time most of them will be trans women so
we'll be fine
it's a joke a little joke a twins a show
on a little high we want to win another
award we do we are going to win awards
for jokes great to see you all that's it
for me what are you up to Keep It
Uncensored keep it award-winning good
night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]